[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
happy friday everyone
[Music]
we are the new kings of late night
massive ratings we destroyed everyone
everyone every host every news they're
gone
it's just me
but also you because you guys did it
because you are the greatest fans and
i've got proof you got to check this
thing out there's a guy in the audience
look what he made guy named bart laro
yeah
hey
you don't have you don't have to clap
for bart you only clap for me
but he built he recreated his entire set
we're using uh legos and he even got
special legos for tyrus cause you know
you need giant legos
for him and cat's uh a a lego which is
approximately the same weight as she is
that amazing
i bet i don't think i don't think don
lemon gets a lego set
i don't even know what that all right
to the monologue
so campus reform has a new video out
where they interview college women on
systemic sexism i wonder does america
oppress women
would you say that women are treated
unfairly in the united states yes i
would say so yes
i've quit so many jobs because of the
way i was treated at work definitely i
think that there's a lot of like
institutional factors that play into
that especially when you think about
just like
like unequal pay we're all we already
have a lower pay wage even if we're
overly qualified for the for the
position there's still a lot of
traditional i guess you could say like
perspectives on like what a woman should
do and what a woman shouldn't do
yeah they're definitely some unfair
treatment in some aspects would you say
that women are oppressed here yes
yeah
yeah absolutely um but it's primarily of
course there's the intersection of not
just being a woman but also being a
woman of color or a poor woman or an
immigrant
so true but i'm not surprised by the
answers this is the college campus where
fresh brains go to die
but what happens when these women are
told about actual oppressors
before the u.s troops invaded
afghanistan the taliban was in control
and under the taliban women weren't
allowed to have a job they weren't
allowed to get an education they weren't
allowed to hold a position in government
they were being beaten and killed under
that government we drove them out and
since then you know life for women in
afghanistan improved greatly because of
u.s presence
so
how does that change their views
yeah
we have it better
we do
i think it does i mean compared to
what's happening in afghanistan i
i mean i do have more basic rights oh
yeah for sure i mean
we still got it a lot better than many
other women in
other countries around the world you
know obviously in other areas it's a lot
worse like with that situation now that
i know like
obviously there's not as much as to
complain about here than over there do
you think we have it pretty good here
it feels like that contradicts what i
say about
but it's the truth though this is a good
question
because you're not you you have a very
fair point we do have it better here
than we do in afghanistan
i love that woman
because she admitted she was wrong in
real time
somebody please send this clip to our vp
stat
that's if anyone can find her
so these students were exposed to new
facts and they changed their minds and i
don't mean exposed in the way that got
me kicked off campus
but we used to call this we used to call
this learning and it's great to see
fact is not everyone on campus is
dim-witted it's just the faculty
sadly the students only get a very
narrow world view fed to them by these
unhappy hate merchants called professors
they don't want thinkers they want
parrots and these parrots blame
everything on the crackers
the creed boils down to this country
sucks and if you're white you suck too
so look it took a while
sorry but it's an easy script to mimic
and many do it to keep the mob away and
also get a good grade so anti-american
hacks repurpose student brains for
imagining everything as a power struggle
which puts their minds in a 24-hour a
day fist fight between what they're
being taught and what they're
experiencing in real life
but when these students hear the other
side of things it's nice to see the
effects if we're lucky they might escape
college with an education but this
national self-loathing isn't something
you find only on campus it's infiltrated
every nook and cranny like so much
butter on brian stelter's morning bagel
yeah
it's considered a requirement for our
cultural conversation except it's stupid
and toxic like drinking windex while
watching the real housewives of new
jersey
so you so you find it in movies tv and
of course sports if you're someone who
loves this country and you watch a
netflix movie and nbc sitcom and stephen
colbert all in the same night your
spouse or the cops will find you the
next morning with your head in the oven
and a suicide note that reads i
apologize for 400 years of oppression
but this america is no better and
possibly worse perspective might be the
easiest way to pass yourself off as a
caring intellect when ironically it's
inversely proportional to actual wisdom
almost everyone who claims women are
routinely paid less than men are
operating on outdated statistics about
income and the work women choose to do
the oil rigs and crab boats await you
ladies the stats always get debunked you
just never hear about it like when
famous female soccer goalie megan repino
claimed how women players were victims
of wage discrimination it was covered
widely in the press what wasn't covered
is widely the california federal court
dismissing the claim after finding out
that the women's soccer team actually
makes more than men on accumulative and
per game basis the women's national team
earned 24 million men earned 18. if
we're up to me they'd both be making
minimum wage that sport makes curling
look like the last five minutes of rocky
sorry soccer players
hope solo the former goalie of the
women's soccer team and my favorite star
wars character
cat told an interviewer that rapino
badgered teammates to support her
spotlight chasing activism others
dispute this claim but you don't have to
be a shrink to see how rapino's strident
act could dampen a spirit it's like that
person in the office that wears too much
perfume or cologne five minutes around
them and you wanna puke
imagine having someone like that at your
place at work
[Music]
hey
why are you all standing in here these
are standing desks standing for what the
patriarchy you work with me you take a
knee all right kneel down kneel down and
turn your back
keep working
hey what the hell are you eating oh
there's this great local sandwich shop
downstairs we only eat subway in this
office all right you want to smash the
fash you gotta throw that in the trash
yeah mom it's my first day at work i'm
having a great time who are you talking
to that's my mother don't you mean
birthing person uh no actually i'm a
doctor
adopt this
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah let me call you back
the new cat had a brother
so i missed the olympics actually i
missed the olympics but so did a lot of
people and why is that the same reason
the nba's ratings are lower than the
taliban's tolerance for string bikinis
give us more winners like tamara mensa
stock wrapped in our flag
and loving
the red white and blue you can keep the
repinos wrapped in endorsement deals and
resentment it's a microcosm of the
current administration who also see
america as the land of hate and
inequality brian's embrace of well coach
woke culture put the stamp of approval
on the grim conviction that america is
eternally guilty of systemic racism and
so how dare we pass judgment on medieval
talents like the taliban we're no better
right
so when you look at attitudes on campus
or on the field you can see how we ended
up fronting a slap dash embarrassing
retreat we sacrificed our moral
standings seeking new ways to punish
fellow americans for thinking for
themselves in place of individual
individuality we have awoke mindlessness
brought to you by our nation's
professors the worst people on earth not
including the taliban yet
let's welcome
[Music]
she's got the top shelf opinions that we
are too short to reach fox news
headlines 24-7 carly shipkids
he became a bank president just for free
checking former oklahoma state
representative t.w shannon
she's got a mind like a steel trap
sharp rusted and filled with dead
squirrels fox news contributor cat tip
and
he's like a deck of cards he has four
suits and your grandmother would love to
get her hands on him fox and friends
weekend host will gain
ugh what an ugly panel we have today
yeah thank god i'm a 10.
so will are you uh what
do you my theory is uh uh is that
somehow
the woke-ism has replaced common sense
and that kind of contributed to our mess
abroad does that make sense or am i miss
stretching it no it makes perfect sense
first of all here's one of my favorite
things about the waters world man on the
street or even better campus reform
because it's on a campus to sit in the
tyra seat it's like a wwe match they
come out i mean fireworks are flaring
it's certainty it's confidence and they
know what they believe and one one
rebuttal or one question and the match
is over in 30 seconds
they fold and crumble like a house of
cards and you saw that in that video and
you you did nail it exactly right it is
a cheat sheet it's a shortcut to
enlightenment to always point to
oppression and they've got all the cheat
sheet lingo in hand you heard them in
that clip institutional or
intersectional if you use all the right
buzzwords you can pass yourself off as
enlightened
unless somebody asks you a question yeah
and then it all goes away tw welcome
back to the show thank you nice uh judd
hurst sweater well thank you
mr rogers called and he wanted it
it's more like judd hurst though from
taxi remember he used to wear that it
was taxi wasn't it no no i digress i
think that there is when general milly
was at that uh what was it a hearing and
he was said he wanted to get at the root
of white rage you kind of realize that
maybe winning wars and keeping america
safe was not really the priority no no
well first of all my name's tw and my
personal pronoun is cracker that's the
first thing i want to get out before we
get started but uh no really you know
this idea that the president united
states would stand and tell people
himself that the greatest threat to
america is white supremacy i mean
it almost is shocking but absolutely
after you think about it's really not
shocking right because they have
continued to press this lie that you
know every single minority in this
country is somehow oppressed by america
this is not the home of systemic racism
this is the home of systemic opportunity
and i think more people
yeah
and
and here's and here's my answer you know
we're going to tie all this into
immigration at some point i would say
i've got a real foolproof plan for
fixing immigration you take you know
obama you take michelle you take oprah
you take all of them and you take them
to the southern border and you let them
explain of how awful a place this is so
that people will stop wanting to come
because the reality is if it was as bad
as they say it is you wouldn't have
people clinging to airplanes trying to
get here yeah yeah it is true it's like
everybo
people are basically supporting america
with their feet by running in one
direction toward it if we were so awful
carly they'd be running away yeah you
know and i've been reading a lot of the
individual stories of what women are
going through right now in afghanistan
you know um the beatings in the streets
are already happening
women are throwing their babies over
fences and um you know it's hard not to
put yourself in their shoes and think
why not me like why am i so lucky to
have this life and by the grace of god
we
we win the lottery just by being
americans and it's not just afghanistan
it's it's north korea it's cuba which is
unfortunately out of the news and yeah
the kids in in that video they've been
taught to feel oppressed and it's cool
to be the victim and some of them will
grow out of it some of them won't but
the one woman that i do want to talk
about american woman is our vice
president and you know young women of
color all over the world we're supposed
to look up to her and i just
i can't stop thinking about what the
young women of color in afghanistan
would be thinking right now if they knew
that she could stay something for them
speak up for them and she is choosing
not to she and president biden came into
the white house being the compassionate
people they were going to bring
compassion back to the white house there
was nothing compassionate about what's
going on right now and you know as a
self-identified woman of color i
how dare you laugh birthing person i'm a
birthing person
although self-identified birthing person
of color yeah there you go yeah you
should see what i birthed in the
bathroom
yes greg yes well done in your um uh
recreation of megan rappino thank you
yeah thank you thank you wow
i love that you guys should all come
over you guys are great uh you did say
she was a goalie though she's not uh
well you could tell by those pictures
they were showing over out on the field
[Laughter]
goalies don't do that they're by the
goal i cannot believe yeah you're
criticizing my sports acumen well i can
because listen i think she has a point
because i've always found it empowering
to say look i've faced sexism i've had
certain trauma in my life i don't like
to be identified by that i you know i'm
gonna work hard but it'd be so much
easier to do the other thing yeah
doesn't even have to be true for example
i'm a woman you're a man okay you you
know you you make more money than i do
and you know that's not we're that we
have the same height
[Laughter]
true so
it has to be gender it could not be that
you have decades more experience that
you this is your show and i'm just the
sidekick or that you have another
successful show that you're on could not
be that no no no gender if i would say
that i would get so many retweets and
i'd be cool and i'd get sponsorships
but i can't be that stupid
yes yes
all right well i think hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else